how's it going bros my name is welcome
to the broken podcast I mean with the
toasty man with chosen it's welcome
right now and guest second time you're
on as a guest
how does it feel it feels amazing thanks
for having back I'd like to thank my mom
my dog I love you love you bro
or you have been on the Illuminati tour
don't tell me it's a three-month tour so
we are all three youtubers yeah all show
me the proof I want to say big online
I'm big in Japan it hurts to say it I'm
big right now
okay everyone everyone play this in the
background so you get in the mood oh I
like what rhymes with Jack crack sack
crack cocaine how do you inhale crack
jack through a line jacksepticeye's line
is booper dooper than Pluto pooper
backwards is reboot I mean Repub reprove
sounds like boob boobs are nice
jacksepticeye is nice have you opened
your eyes yet
nice it's a city in France France played
against Ireland in Rugby World Cup rugby
it's a sport for men Hugh Jackman yes
man in his name Jackman has a funny
accent
so does - except Takei 9/11 was an
accident or was it look between the
lines accidents happen
life happens life is life nananananana
Jackie lives in Ireland Ireland sounds
like I assume Illuminati jacksepticeye
Illuminati confirmed all right is it
true Jackie you in the Illuminati well
with that kind of proof I don't think
you can argue anymore it's so certain I
guess we're done here I guess my point
good podcast you guys next time I said
maybe you guys have something to say
about the situation I think I thought
you were gonna do Ken now bided type in
jacksepticeye Illuminati and just that
second picture there if you just stared
at me blankly just don't know how to
believe me think you ever say to me
again Jesus Christ
boom
step blink stare search me on on Google
Felix is there somewhere get my [ __ ]
get out of my [ __ ] tumblr tag [ __ ]
hey I tombliboo turn you do you'd mark
is like half more than half my tumblr
yeah and then Dan and Phil is the other
I'm that one percentage which picture
are you talking about this picture of
you all fabulous instead of saying I'm
fabulous that says I'm a lumen happy I
got some stuff against Felix okay okay
like I can listen to you but alright I
guess I'll everyone is going to agree
with this more than anything you say
okay so Felix is the most subscribed on
YouTube right Oh God but everybody
online seems to hate him what else right
there's no way Bobbi the most subscribed
and the most hated at the same time it
makes no sense it's true okay
you must have some outside help from
somewhere there's something going on
there's you boo okay wait okay everyone
has a love-hate relationship no no
everyone online hates you from what I've
seen he love me they just don't know it
yet goes deeper okay feelings how deep
has moved to three different countries
damn it
Easley Sweden UK my sub goes together
that's how he got all his subs yet
everyone online hates him come on man
these three locations on a map form a
triangle Kay whatever someone helps you
out you know on YouTube you feel like
you gotta give him a shout-out or you
know promote them a little bit and
that's looking at the legend of the
brofist game and the background here
right it looks like a freakin Illuminati
the barrel Cain on his neck oh right
teaming up on me frequently enemies
Illuminati enemies exactly the three
locations came out I'd say that I gotta
say the like Gothenburg Italy and
frightened makes like the perfect
triangle exactly I'm telling you it's
there
the name PewDiePie has three syllables
in it Illuminati confirmed right there I
didn't even need a long story why why
three like the triangle is that it yeah
three sites were trying oh boy three
locations three different countries it's
it the proof is right there I don't need
you didn't say anything against kin I've
stuff against Ken ken has three letters
in it
Ken's YouTube name is cinnamon toast Ken
which has three words in it
if they are you transforming into a
lizard right alligator / Illuminati it
equals king